hey what's up guys it's rob today i'm
going to show you how to make the
origami dollar ring what you're going to
need is a dollar bill if you have a 5 a
20 a 50 it doesn't matter any american
bill will work except with the bigger
bills the number is wider so it doesn't
tend to fit on this little square
portion as nicely as the one does
so i do recommend using a single dollar
bill i am aware that i have viewers and
subscribers in other countries who don't
have access to american bills not to
worry you could try to use a bill from
your country but i'm also going to show
you
how to modify a regular piece of printer
paper i'll give you the proper
dimensions that you need to cut out a
little portion and you can follow along
with printer paper and come up with
something that looks like this this
one's cool because you can actually draw
on it so even if you do have american
money if you want to make one that you
could draw on then you could follow
along with printer paper so once you
have a piece of paper or a dollar bill
you're ready to go
for those of you using printer paper you
need to cut out a portion of the paper
that is six centimeters in width by 15.5
centimeters in length
when you do that you'll find you have a
piece of paper that looks like this
now this is not the exact same width as
a dollar bill
it's actually a little bit shorter in
width and the reason for that is because
the first fold in making the origami
dollar ring will be to first of all hold
the dollar with the back side facing
towards you then we're going to fold the
top of the dollar bill away from us
along the border between the green here
and the lighter color here
so right along this little line is where
you want to fold
the
top of the bill down away from you and
you want to do that all the way across
the top of the bill
so fold it down away from you it's
probably easier to hold the bill in your
hand so that you can hold see that line
a little better
so fold it down all the way across just
like that
[Applause]
and then you'll have something that
looks like this
now you'll notice that
the paper is around the same width as
the dollar bill with the top portion
folded you wouldn't be able to fold that
little
portion down on the plain paper because
you don't have that border so once you
have
this paper for those of you using
printer paper take the top half and
we're going to fold it in half
lengthwise
and then what i want you to do is to
fold the top end onto the midline the
bottom end onto the midline just like
that
and then fold the whole thing in half
and now
those of you using printer paper should
be able to follow along as i go through
the folds
with the dollar bill okay so once you
fold that top portion of the dollar bill
away from you along that border we're
going to flip the bill over completely
and then we're going to take the top
edge
of the bill which is the bottom of the
bill i'm going to take the top edge and
we're going to fold it down
all the way until it meets the very
bottom of the bill now which is right
here along this fold
so fold it down until the edges line up
just like that
and then make a crease along the top
now we're going to tuck this edge
underneath
this fold that we made previously
so just round it off a little bit
and you want to tuck it underneath
that fold there
just like that
and then just make sure everything is
still nice and flat
so it should look something like this
now we're going to take the very bottom
edge of the bill and we're going to fold
it up
to the very top of the bill
so take the very bottom edge and you
want to basically again
line up the edges so fold this bottom
edge up to the top
just like that
so that the edges once again line up
and then make sure everything is nice
and flat by making really good creases
so you should have something that looks
just like this
okay so as you'll notice the printer
paper and the dollar bill have about the
same length and width
what we're going to do now is we're
going to box out or frame the one on the
left side of the dollar bill so that it
appears on front of the origami ring
once we've finished it
on the printer paper we don't have a one
there so it makes it a little trickier
to kind of figure out where you need to
make the folds but i'm going to show you
how to do it on the dollar bill and you
should be able to figure it out on the
printer paper to border or frame the
left side of the one we're going to fold
back this lighter portion along that
line there just like we did for the top
of the dollar
so just fold it backwards
on that line and make a crease
now we're going to frame the right side
of the one so take the rest of the
dollar bill and fold it back
behind the one
until the area around the one is in the
shape of a square just like that
now you can make a crease on the right
side
so now you'll see we have the one facing
towards us
what we're going to do now is we're
going to give the ring a curve
so what you're going to do is you're
going to pinch the one that we folded
just like that
and we're going to rotate the rest of
the dollar bill in a clockwise direction
now you don't want to rotate
the rest of the bill
towards this fold so it should not be
folded like this
hold the one facing towards you
like that and rotate the rest of the
bill
in a clockwise direction around your
finger
and then you can kind of push
on the outside like this
and when you let go you'll see the ring
now has a nice curve
so now you want to hold it
so that this one is folded away from you
like this
and we're going to take the right end
now
and we're going to fold the bottom edge
upwards until it's in between the o and
the f
so take the right edge and fold it up
so that it flies in between the bottom
edge lies in between the o and the f
just like that
and then you can make a crease
and that sets the diameter of the ring
to a certain size now if you want to
make the ring
wider like that
you would fold the bottom edge further
down to the right like this if you want
to make it more narrow you could fold it
further to the left like that
but a good size is having the edge in
between the o and the f
right
there
so make a crease a good crease there
and now what we're going to do you'll
see the ring is curving in this
direction
so hold it like this and we're going to
rotate both ends together
until the one is lying on top
of this little fold that we made so
rotate it
and as you'll see
you should have that resting on top of
that fold
now the right border of the one
should be lined up with the bottom of
the bill here
so now what you want to do is you're
going to unfold the one
like that
and then we're going to take this excess
that's underneath
uh this portion of the bill here
and you're going to fold it down
underneath where the one was and as
you'll see the right the border here the
edge of the bill
should be lined up with the right border
of the one so you don't you don't want
to have it like this where it's not
lined up
you need to have it lined up just like
that
so take the excess fold it down
and then you want to take the one and
fold it back down on top of the end of
the bill
and we're going to take
the little the left border of the one
this little portion that we folded back
we're going to put it
underneath this excess portion that we
just folded down towards us
so you want to tuck it underneath there
like that
and then what we're going to do
is we're going to take the excess and
we're again going to fold it inside of
the ring now so just round it off
and fold it inside of the ring
like that
and then we're going to turn it around
and as you'll see we have a little bit
of a pocket here
so what you want to do is you want to
open that pocket with your finger
and you're going to take the remaining
portion of the end of the bill
and you're going to tuck it
into that little pocket
and it could get a little bit tricky
so
try to tuck it in
and if you're having some trouble
then you can take
the end of a pencil
and just kind of work it in there
and then you can squash it down
and there you go you have an origami
dollar ring
thank you for watching my tutorial for
making the origami dollar ring i hope
that you found the tutorial easy to
follow let me know what you thought of
it by leaving a comment in the comment
section below and don't forget to rate
and subscribe by clicking the little
like button down below the video and the
yellow subscribe button up to the left